This is the old one.
There we go.
Yes.
Today.
Just a dream.
I don't remember.
Maro Stylo Barbie to endo.
Matt
out of Ram in a mad reason.
Seasons change.
Leave me out in the cold
stone is,
Oh
man,
this guy
is full of Dallas pocket La got above him and cry.
Sure.
Bye.
Damn
good.
Go tap
my watch.
Miss Shine
man.
Lo Waxman.
Shy.
Now word man.
Watch me shine,
man.
Free from sin.
Cast the first stone.
Gan.
Yeah.
Those words speak whole nuts in his full spread.
Yep.
The News Literacy is one movie in the sunshine.
Choose rec now has passed through lag time.
Watch me shine.
Stay
Watch mission.
No.
Watch me
the crowns.
No.
And
gas
man.
You can always get well no.
Yeah,
no
presses
to pull out too.
We
watch miss shine,
man.
No
Man.
No.
Now Watch me.
Watch me.
Watch me shine.
Boom.
That was beautiful.
That was fucking beautiful,
goddammit.
Thank you,
sir.
Oculus Shit.
It's over now.
Now you've raised it.
Blew the exercise.
All the demon all over.
We're going.
Okay.